given the astounding success of The Last
of Us hopefully this gives Studios a
much better outlook on wanting to do
high quality video game adaptations and
ones that are actually faithful to the
source material that's the major
distinction because there's been a lot
so far that don't follow the source
material at all Halo and The Last of Us
is proof that there's a ton of unmind
potential within the video game sphere
because we are basically just getting
started for the first game on this list
since the last of us has had
groundbreaking success it only makes
sense to adapt God of War initially upon
writing this I didn't even know that
Amazon acquired the rights to do an
adaptation of God of War back in
December 2022 there hasn't really been
any updates about it so also go into why
this could make such a great adaptation
even though it's announced now this
would be a very challenging game to
adapt giving now a huge the scale of it
is along with the budget you're probably
needing to be massive out of all the
studios to acquire though Amazon would
most likely be willing to write a blank
check for the show given that the rings
of power costed over a billion dollars
however if they didn't want to casually
drop another billion dollars he could
start the show at God of War 2018. the
budget will still need to be pretty
large but at least the story will be
more manageable to tell at a slightly
smaller scale in comparison to the first
three games given that at its core it's
primarily a father and son Adventurer so
that's a pretty easy story to tackle for
a show format Kratos and atris are
complex characters and their Rich
Dynamic will anchor down the story
Kratos learns to become a better father
and opens up to his son while atreus
learns to become more mature and to be
more like a warrior there's a strong
progression for both of these characters
so every dialogue scene they have
together should be very engaging that's
one thing that most video game
adaptations require if it doesn't have a
strong base story with great characters
then it would be really hard to
translate it over to shows and movies
like the biggest example of this is Doom
there really isn't much of a a story or
characters in Doom and is predominantly
carried by its gameplay it does have
some cool background lore but you also
need a great plot for shows and movies
you can't just have non-stop action with
barely any dialogue because if you do
that you won't be able to form an
attachment to the characters and the
audience will slowly stop caring about
the narrative a good story makes you
care about the action and without one
you won't be invested or have any stakes
in the action so on the other side of
this coin you have God of War Two
lovable characters who go on a fun
journey across the Realms any action
along the way is investing because you
like the characters and you want to see
them achieve their goal I just wanted to
quickly go over that because I won't be
including games that are solely based on
good gameplay going into how much meat
God of War has to offer you can easily
do a whole season per game at least
pretending to the last two God of Wars I
think there's enough there and even
though there are some repetitive section
within those games you can cut them out
and tighten up the pace for the
narrative I also think think that
choosing God of War 2018 as a starting
point will make Kratos an even more
intriguing character given how
mysterious his past is because
throughout the game the writers allude
to what happened in the past so if
anything skipping the first three games
won't hinder the overall story because
God of War 2018 essentially hits the
restart button you can start it at the
very beginning and go into the tragedy
of kratos's origin but you'll have to
make some heavy changes to the story
because I'd assume viewers won't want to
watch Kratos go to the underworld three
separate times out of all the
adaptations I'll be going into this is
at the top of my list another dream come
true would be a proper adaptation of
Halo since the Paramount Plus show
doesn't exist to me now this is much
harder material to adapt in comparison
to other games given that Master Chief
is kind of just a vessel for the player
he has extremely light characterization
in only Halo 4 really makes an effort to
humanize him so telling his story if
anything kinda feels like a trap you'd
either have to make major changes to a
source material to make Master Chief
more of a character similar to the
Paramount Plus show so that you can
sympathize and relate to him but also
not like the show where they make him
overly emotional he barely has his
helmet on and they even give him nude
scenes or if you don't make any changes
to Master Chief you have a main
protagonist that barely talks I keep
seeing people say that they would love a
show with this faithfulness to Chief but
again without a proper character to be
attached to who barely speaks or emotes
then the story will have a hard time
operating games can get away with this
because it's more objective based and
you become the character for shows and
movies we witness a story without having
any input since Master Chief would be
very difficult to adapt without ruining
him I would recommend adapting a story
within the Halo Universe that doesn't
involve Chief or at least doesn't make
him the main character that may be a
controversial opinion but that also
seems to be the most realistic and
easiest of the options there's also a
lot of material to choose from that
doesn't even include Master Chief but
I'll only look at the existing games
currently the most adaptable and that
also happens to be one of the best
stories is Halo Reach This is an
outstanding setting and witnessing a
society collapse from an alien invasion
is awesome Halo Reach also has a good
roster of characters now they aren't as
rich as the main characters in The Last
of Us in God of War but it wouldn't
betray The Source material to expand
upon these characters they're all pretty
distinct and varied so you'll be able to
make some good pairings throughout the
miniseries which is what I think Halo
Reach will fit the best as each Mission
would lend pretty well to a separate
episode given that they are consistently
changing settings and in each episode
they can spend time developing a certain
character within the squad with the main
character also for the main character he
doesn't have much of her personality and
is even more of a vessel for the player
than Master Chief so you'll have to
change him and make him an actual
character you can lead into how he's
pitched as in the game in which he's a
lone wolf with a mysterious past this
could naturally offer us a point of
conflict between in the main character
and the team and through the story he
learns the value of teamwork and is
reinvigorated by the camaraderie of his
new family thus changing him into a
character with more heart and someone
with warmth at first he could be
doubtful about the effectiveness of his
team in attempts to get things done on
his own in a selfish Manner and is more
closed off then through the course of
the show all these negative aspects are
peeled away through different selfless
and kind acts made by his team I think
this could offer a solid character Arc
for noble 6 and can easily add a deeper
layer to him that you don't have to make
him the main character since he'll
inherently be a bit unlikable towards
the beginning so instead you could
mostly focus on the squad as a whole
while slowly pivoting towards Noble Six
as being the main point of view who is
slowly winning the hearts of the
audience the overall story arc for Halo
Reach is pretty great and I would go
into more depth about it but that would
be going into spoilers and I kinda want
to stay away from them in this video
since I'll be touching on a wide array
of games but the story acts as a Mad
Dash to save Humanity in the squad we
follow are integral in that goal in the
actions they may carry a massive amount
of weight this can easily be a very epic
fun and emotional Journey carried out by
this lovable Squad of Spartans it's just
really depressing that this probably
won't come to fruition for a while given
that Paramount plus is doing their own
show and that doesn't even follow the
source material
man that [__] piss me off man dead space
this is a game that I'm genuinely
surprised hasn't been adapted into a
horror movie yet or even hearing any
development around a possible movie
because between everything on this list
this is probably the easiest material to
adapt because of the simple premise of
the game This Crew responds to a
distress signal in space and they are
met with nightmarish and Eldritch
Horrors and the crew then has to escape
the premise in of itself is perfect for
a movie and the atmosphere in the game
is extremely immersive the dilapidating
interiors blood-soaked and terrifying
displays of Gore and body horror thrown
throughout the environment creepy
lighting and atmosphere that always
hammers home a feeling of dread this is
literally a perfect horror environment
in the hands of a competent horror
director this should be a Surefire hit
even though the premise itself isn't
entirely original the designs of the
monsters and how everything operates is
very intriguing like the mystery behind
the the marker and how it affects people
would constantly keep a hook in the
audience along with it potentially being
cool visually how the filmmakers would
portray the hysteria induced by the
marker as for how the story of the game
translates to a movie it should
definitely be cut down because the game
is mostly a string of objectives of
repairing the ishimura having to repair
basically the entire ship was mostly a
story mechanic to artificially elongate
the game this is fine for the game
because they keep introducing new
gameplay elements to keep things fresh
and interesting but for a movie you need
to keep the narrative moving at a
satisfying pace so any filmmaker would
definitely need to cut it down and from
there you could cherry pick the many
horror set pieces from the game that and
the climax is pretty insane so the
ending should definitely still be great
for the movie in terms of budget it
should definitely be pretty manageable
because most of the game takes place in
closed Interiors meaning that you could
shoot all this on enclosed sets on a
Sound Stage the amount of VFX shouldn't
be too crazy and I'd much prefer to see
some practical Necromorphs if any
filmmaker were to go with solely VFX
Necromorphs and that would be extremely
saddening but overall I'd assume this
will probably be adapted soon especially
since the popularity around the game has
surged from the outstanding reception of
the remake
Bioshock now this game has been blue
balling Gamers because there has been
news about a movie for this game raging
back to pre-2010 Studios were scared to
make the movie because making a very
high budget rated R movie seemed like a
guaranteed flaw however a year and a
half ago it was announced that this game
is actually being developed by Netflix
and a partnership with 2K Games it's
being directed by Francis Lawrence who
directed the last three Hunger Games and
I am Legend So it's in the hands of a
competent director and the studio that
developed the game is involved the only
thing about this adaptation though and
why I'm including this is that we
haven't received much updates about this
project and that makes me worried given
what happened in the past but going into
why Bioshock would make a magnificent
adaptation is because it checks off a
lot of boxes the world of rapture is
incredibly immersive and is a constant
visual Feast the underwater city lends
itself to so many unique and cool set
pieces of withering structures that have
so much environmental storytelling the
entire background and behind the
architecture is just so intriguing and
so is all the stories surrounding it
this could lead to such a
thought-provoking script because the
world is constantly oozing with so much
subtext about what happened to the
cystopian society it has engaging themes
like that of class inequality unchecked
capitalism an abuse of power leading to
the fall of the city there's also a lot
of vibrant and unhinged characters
throughout this world and given that
there's so much dialogue communicated
over a radio there should never be any
down moments within the spreads along
with there being an outstanding twist
towards the end of the game that
completely shatters your perception of
the story then there's also the
brilliant designs of the augmented
humans like slicers and big daddies that
would be so cool to see done in live
action really every aspect about the
game carried over into a movie or
miniseries setting will be an instant
classic so hopefully Netflix actually
commits to making this project and gives
them a big enough budget because another
thing that makes me really excited about
the Netflix adaptation is that it's
being written by the writer of Blade
Runner 2049 that pays an overall
aesthetic from that movie would fit
perfectly in BioShock and if they
somehow got Roger deakins as a
cinematographer then I'd probably pass
out
Resident Evil 7. this would be a pretty
simple adaptation honestly and the main
reason why I'm choosing the seventh
entries because a it's not an overly
complex story and is mainly about
surviving this crazy family and B
there's been a lot of failed adaptations
for the first couple of games so I'd
like to see them try some different
games in the franchise I admittedly
haven't played Resident Evil 4 yet and
really want to so I wouldn't be
surprised if that would also make for a
great movie as well but for Resident
Evil 7 making it a pure horror movie of
Ethan slowly trying to overcome the
psychotic hillbilly family with powers
would make for a riveting ride it's also
extremely similar to the original Texas
Chainsaw Massacre so the story should
already function within a movie or mini
series format if it weren't in mini
series format you could have each
episode where Ethan overcomes one of the
members of the family and thus becomes
more hardened as a character or if it
were a movie you can condense down some
of the set pieces a bit and make it a
perfect two hours like ideally probably
we cut out the whole boat sequence which
felt a bit weird and try to tackle the
same story Revelation in a different
manner I would go into that more but I'm
refraining from going into spoilers
talking about it vaguely though the
general background to the story and how
this family ended up the way they did is
really a tragedy and it uncovers a whole
another layer to the story that gives it
a lot of depth and doesn't just make
this family a bunch of psychos it makes
them a lot more sympathetic and by the
end of the game you kind of just feel
bad for them the main character would
probably need a little bit more
characterization but at the end of the
day it is really A Story of Survival and
that is always a great time for horror
movies
OverWatch I'm honestly really surprised
I'd even have to include this game
because you'd assume that blizzard would
have made an animated movie or series by
this point like the game has been out
for seven years God damn I feel old now
however as I was making this video
blizzard did release an animated
miniseries for OverWatch although it's
extremely short in length and for that
run time it was pretty good so the
question stands why the hell isn't
blizzard Contracting Studios to make
longer form content it's definitely not
a money issue since blizzard as a
company is reeling in one to two billion
dollars of net income a year so green
lighting an animated series or movie
shouldn't be that big of a deal and if
anything it would just make them more
money it's maddening because the
possibilities are truly endless and you
can go into so many outstanding
directions for an OverWatch series you
could go the Arcane routes and make a
rich and grounded drama and go into the
complexities of the world and select
characters you could go down to more
anthology energy routes where each
episode follows one or a few Heroes as
they carry out their most important
missions or you can even make the show
like that amazing and epic Clone Wars
show back in the day where you have
massive battles with a huge scale
literally the possibilities are endless
and I'd assume you'd love to watch any
of the three pitches I mentioned so the
fact that we really have none of that is
truly heartbreaking from the untapped
potential there are so many cool and
interesting characters that I would love
to learn more about the game only
scratches the surface for these
characters in terms of development and
it feels like fans have been blue balled
for so long in terms of getting to know
them more for me personally I only know
the surface level for each of the
characters in OverWatch and I would love
to get a deep dive and learn much more
about them that in the world of
OverWatch is definitely intriguing
enough to carry a show so when cuphead
of all IPS gets three seasons before
blizzard does practically anything with
OverWatch is really depressing I don't
know what the hell management is doing
over there and surely all the money
they're milking out of play players with
absurge shot prices and battle passes
can give them enough money for a proper
show
Red Dead Redemption 2. out of Rockstar's
catalog this seems like the best pick
which isn't downplaying GTA 5 which
could also make for an interesting
miniseries but I think the story for Red
Dead Redemption 2 is a bit better a
group of Outlaws who are all colorful
and sympathetic in their own way would
make for a fun perspective to follow for
a big sprawling Adventure they're all
essentially anti-heroes in morally
complex characters who aren't just good
or bad and that makes riveting subjects
in my opinion along with a deep dynamic
in synergies between all of them the
main reason why I'm breaking up Red Dead
Redemption 2 besides the fact that it
has a great story is that westerns in
general have really fallen off over the
years which is kind of sad to be honest
they used to be so dominant back in the
day and there are really only a small
handful of good westerns that have come
out in the last 10 years so it would be
really exciting to see a big return to
this genre that would ideally be
followed by a big budget which this
would also kind of be a first in that we
don't have that many other big budget
Western period chose the only tier that
come to mind is Deadwood and Hell on
Wheels so there's basically no
competition right now for this area and
I would love the variety that and I
think Red Dead Redemption 2 could find a
really good balance between story slash
character development and action given
that there are many action set pieces in
the game that could easily be
cherry-packed but yeah rdr2 seems like a
pretty easy layup to the point that I'm
surprised no Studios have taken an
interest in it yet
little nightmares now this may be a
surprise to you that I'm including this
game and some of you may not have heard
of little nightmares it's an indie
horror game in which you have to
navigate a hostile malformed and Dark
World with Horrors awaiting around every
corner the monster designs in this game
are really unsettling and plays into the
childlike perspective of exaggerated
Horrors the world is extremely harsh and
foreboding for you as a player and there
is so much detail within the world that
that is the main driver for storytelling
every environment tells a deeply tragic
and dark story that as he progress
through the game it's like you are
slowly piecing together a jigsaw puzzle
as to what happened here there's also no
dialogue within the game so it makes the
mystery of this world that much more
alluring so right away I think this
would make for a perfect stop-motion
horror Adventure the crazy thing is that
this project was actually being
developed and it was oddly enough being
spearheaded by Anthony and Joe Russo I
honestly just chanced upon the project
as I was looking through the other IMDb
page but the little nightmares
adaptation was going to be directed by
the legendary Henry Selleck who directed
both The Nightmare Before Christmas and
Coraline so the potential behind this
project was huge and it's really
depressing that the project ended up
fizzling out because this world fits
perfectly for that kind of dark
stop-motion aesthetic along with the
story actually being pretty riveting
especially for the second game in which
there are some pretty big and surprising
twists so yeah I just wanted to call out
this game since the world is so
immersive and would be a really fun
adventure if the right Talent wanted to
make it
Gears of War similar to Bioshock it
feels like Gears of War has been in a
Perpetual development hell for
adaptations and again like Bioshock it
seems that Netflix is stepping in and
making it a reality the main reason why
I'm including this game is that I really
love the premise of the game and it
could make for a cool gritty sci-fi War
epic these kind of genre Blends are
really rare and that is why I'm craving
it so much and so are you most likely
just like Halo fighting a war against an
alien-like threat where we are actively
learning about them as The Story Goes On
makes a threat much more terrifying
along with her being cool reveals for
different enemy types throughout the
story to keep things fresh and exciting
there's so many fun and cool set pieces
through the initial Trilogy to the point
that they can definitely do a movie for
each game like I would love to see the
worms at peace from the second game
without going into spoilers then from a
story and character perspective you can
definitely create a solid Pace since
every character is pretty varied and
iconic I'd love some actual sit-down
scenes with these characters since we
don't really get that from the games all
the dialogue is done while they're
walking through the world when they
aren't engaged in combat but each of
their backstories are deep enough to be
explored to a good extent like the main
character Marcus has an era of mystery
to him in the first game as to why he's
locked up in what he did along with his
World Views fundamentally contrasting
different characters that and his strict
and mean Persona has a fun Dynamic with
other characters who are more
light-hearted and fun so from a world
Story character and action perspective
this should be easily accomplishable
with a good budget that I hope Netflix
commits to and actually provides Dave
Bautista is practically begging to be in
the movie so please make that a reality
now for my last pick there's quite a few
games that I would love to see like an
Outlast horror movie someone trying to
tackle the rich world of Half-Life or
even a fun Blockbuster Call of Duty
action movie but for the last game I'll
talk about is Wolfenstein and the reason
why I'm choosing this game is that I
think it could be a very fun and over
the top action movie or show given that
the games have so many crazy enemies
like oversized robotic Panzer hounds or
colossal mechs of the Nazis somehow made
it's just such a batshit ridiculous
concept that you can't help but love how
creative and fun it is so the style of
filmmaking that I would absolutely love
to see attached to the Wolfenstein
franchise is Bollywood filmmaking this
would make a perfect pairing because the
over-exaggerated aspects of action in
those movies that clearly don't follow
logic and are just there to emphasize
and Elevate the action past reality
would mix perfectly with the crazy world
of Wolfenstein like I don't care make
Blasco is a [__] god-like entity in
the game who can dualed massive machine
guns and solo the entire Nazi army if
you purely go off the rails with the
action then the fans would adore this
project now the story concept has been
done before but I would love to see it
done in the Bollywood action style I
know I said in the beginning of the
video that gameplay dominated games
won't make for great adaptations but I
think we'll Wolfenstein saw as a solid
story it fits in really well into the
story Dynamic of an underdog and would
make the conflict that blaskowitz has to
overcome pretty riveting along with
there being some vibrant and fun
characters along the way it's not like
the games don't have any story because
there's actually quite a bit of
cinematic storytelling within the series
this obviously won't rival like The Last
of Us for storytelling quality but the
action is the true highlight here
because who wouldn't love watching Nazis
get obliterated in the most insane ways
possible that would be my dream from an
action standpoint for this IP and from
there you could really do whatever you
want with the story and depart from The
Game's for all I care the main game does
have a pretty iconic villain besides
just Hitler but you can really make any
villain within that world iconic with
creative and out there designs so would
anyone actually make this and would this
be a realistic dream probably not I know
Studios would actually have the balls to
make this however given that Twisted
Metal didn't really take itself
seriously and was a fun Joyride then
this type of adaptation could be
possible by the way I have a patreon and
this video is voted on by my patrons so
if you want to support me check out the
different tiers and the link is in the
description thank you for watching and
let me know what video game adaptations
you'd want to see the most in the
comments
please